in a state known for political surprises
this wasn't one of them the polls
predicted a win for Donald Trump and the
Republican front runner delivered for a
third time in New Hampshire this is an
evening uh that I will not forget
because it's the third time but more
importantly uh I think it's going to be
I think it's going to be the most
important time he banks the state
alongside his win in Iowa just over a
week ago he believes that almost assures
the presidency when you win Iowa and you
in New Hampshire they've never had a
loss there had been a steady stream of
Voters across the state throughout the
day many of whom gave a hint of a surge
for the former un Ambassador Nikki Haley
in the end it wasn't enough but with a
performance better than predicted she's
not giving up and taking the fight to
her home state South Carolina at one
point in this campaign there were 14 of
us running and we were at 2% in the
polls well I'm a
fighter and I'm
Scrappy and now we're the last one
standing next to Donald
Trump South Carolina voters don't want a
coronation they want an
election Trump won because he was able
to maintain his hold on the Republican
party uh he has spent a lot of his
energy since he was elected into 2016
making uh the being a good Republican
being a member of the Republican party
uh equivalent to supporting Donald Trump
and being a trump supporter on the
Democratic side a r over timing of the
primary meant the result isn't
recognized by the national party but it
was still a win for Joe Biden not on the
ballot but picking up right in
endorsements Nikki Hy is in trouble she
said she would win New Hampshire and she
didn't she will come under pressure to
step aside so the Republicans can HS
around one candidate Donald Trump and
also save their money for November's
general election because Joe Biden has
built up a significant War chest the
2024 election will be a rerun of what
happened in 2020 and America remembers
how bitter that was and how much of that
bitterness still hasn't gone away Alan
Fischer Al jazer Manchester New
Hampshire make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer